honey
I have some crazy [ __ ] he took it to
heart
made it all the way back he was talking
about quitting comedy the whole time and
I was like it's really interesting
is it a Splat this looks like a splash
but this looks like almost like what are
we working water and then it like it's
like a drip can you tilt it more up yeah
yeah like what
oh that's good
and ambidextrous that's what that means
okay try to get that one pointed out
then
you guys have hair and shirt match hey
all right
James Kinsey
always interesting making friends right
yeah yeah
comic as well
yeah we're from Dallas next yeah
yesterday
yeah you got shows tonight or no so
again you guys are going up tonight
I mean are you offering I have no power
here I'm
I used all the the coupons I had to get
on shows this week so that's why you
brought a pay to film in yeah yeah
this happened yeah this happened and
wait you were saying this is your first
time in Austin yeah to do I spent one
night here like years ago Couchsurfing
on my way through town it's very often
yeah yeah and then uh this is my first
time doing
did those reach I don't think
are they just Tangled yeah
and they're Health better but come
okay it's live now all right it's live
hello hello so Kenzie how's the uh how's
the Austin scene treating you
same here yeah
uh did you guys do anything like open
mics or
I had a show yesterday at Creek in the
cake yeah Best of the West yeah yeah
Dean Stanfield yeah he wasn't there
though
um
he's like uh black comic
it's like here's the show I'm not on it
okay okay
I thought I just talked a lot about the
difference between white people and
black people or something I don't know
and I was like what it what does that
mean exactly or he just happens to be
black and a comic no he's white he looks
white as [ __ ] oh he's got a mullet
and I am very confused right now yeah
yeah by what Batman sorry about that
what do you guys think about uh
the uh the the Mar-A-Lago raid by Trump
or the FBI on Trump's house
right there
oh nice nice do you know who that was
yeah I don't know anybody in this book
there is a lot of kerfuffle about you
know like should they have done it
yeah I don't know I'm sure they're I'm
sure if he gets the presidency in 2024
he'll just do that to Biden and his
laptop right yeah if he's breaking the
law but I mean and I guess those are
things like they thought they had
evidence that he had like taken
something right they had taken some type
of doctor they took it back apparently
but yeah I heard that uh Trump made a
law that makes it a felony to reveal
classes or like mishandle classified
information to get back at Hillary
Clinton because she did that with the
servers and that's the law that he broke
which he made a felony so he broke a law
that he created
is that the first time like you wonder
if that's the first time it's happened
to a president like I'm going to make
this law and then like four months
immediately I feel like that happens
every presidency yeah
someone's listening to Obama right now
like thanks for the wiretap and Bill you
[ __ ] idiot right right I can hear
everything he gets drone striked himself
all right it went bad is it because he's
a black president I just want to clarify
if that's the yeah
it's because
was that mine because you were a little
higher you're a little hot listen listen
I heard what you said we're toning it
down our little wonky yeah
these are good stage mics yeah yeah
they're both 58s yep nice it's all you
need according to Brian redband dude
sm58 sir that's the most like durable
mic stage mic for any type of
performance like those things those are
the ones you see in like all the videos
from like 20 years ago or whatever like
rockstars like swinging them and
throwing them and dropping them and all
that they can just like they just keep
going there's actually a YouTube video
where uh they shot it with a shotgun
like an actual shotgun and then it still
works afterwards
yeah does it affect the sound at all
it's I mean it's like it's a great live
mic thing obviously it's way like those
are what SM 57s yeah these are for you
know very podcast Radio voice over yeah
yeah yeah my voice sounds kind of deep
here guys actually I think that's clear
and Crisp that's how your voice is okay
yeah
I actually sound like this yeah that's
what you sound like holy [ __ ] you sound
like Sam Kinison all the time from the
50s
uh
the other guy uh Ben Costello and the
first one the guy that Lenny Bruce and
Bruce just yelling from the stage
reading court documents that will happen
that's too much of a compliment I feel
like yeah I used to do heroin did you
know that Hans did you no
when did you do heroin when I used to
live here in Austin and now you're back
so you're about to relapse that's weird
thinking about it yeah it depends on how
this podcast goes how old were you you
don't seem you seem like a young man how
old were you when you were doing heroin
23. 100 now he's a 35. you look amazing
um how'd you get in the heroin what led
to heroin uh I was just experimenting
with drugs all the drugs yeah and then I
would do drugs for like a month straight
and then heroin's just the one that got
benzos almost got me a little bit but
nobody teaches you stuff it was like
benzo heroinza and then heroin just ran
away with the lead uh yeah but I was
like experimenting like I tried DMT when
I was down here and stuff which that was
like you know this is even before Joe
Rogan was really talking about it and um
well you were wow look at you yeah
uh yeah so what what was your what made
you decide just like I'm gonna try all
the drugs
because I tried pot and it was really
great gateway drug clearly no no but
that's because they made it they put in
the same doors right as you know and
yeah the guy selling your pot also
offers you cocaine and Other Drugs yeah
and prefers to sell you the hardest yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh no because they lied
to you you know like the whole dare
program they lied to me about pot or
then I was like what do they learn about
other drugs well love Nirvana too I
think it's good enough for Kurt Cobain
so you went from Wheats to straight
heroin no wait what was the progression
yeah it was uh I guess booze for or
cigarettes booze weed uh and then like
ecstasy and then
Xanax and then maybe some meth or like
Adderall and stuff and then and then oh
cocaine somewhere in there um okay yeah
you just didn't think that there was
real you're like I don't well they lied
about the basic fundamental things about
pot you know where they're saying you're
gonna get addicted and don't get me
wrong like I've had a habit forming
times the pot where I'm soaking pot all
the time but it's like yeah that's not
the problem and he steals people's drugs
for sure it's still your drugs this is
true and I tell you but yeah yeah after
he took them sometimes I took your truck
occasionally yeah occasionally yeah
or you start trying to share your drugs
back with you like hey I have this
you're like that's mine she cries on all
the drugs this is true I can't all the
drugs you cry not weed but yeah any of
them tears of happiness and I mean most
of them I feel like are tears of
happiness or Jesus have very expressive
eyes I guess
actually when uh we used to see each
other I said she looked very pretty when
she cried so he would try to make me cry
no that's not true it just happened
naturally yeah yeah he was like you
haven't cried in a while take this yeah
yeah I should do that I should do that
yeah in the sense of being like hey like
you need to release a little yeah you
should go to a funeral high and then
they'll be like oh she's crying nice she
cares like wedding dresses yeah yeah
yeah but with funerals so how long did
it take for you crying about the
unicorns
the unicorns
how long did it take for you to go from
like I'm gonna try drugs to I have a
heroin problem
18 they're like 23 and then I had that
for about I got off methadone like a
year and a half ago two maybe almost two
years now
wait 23 and you're 35 now yeah
so that's a that was a long battle
yeah I mean some of it was because of
the court stuff like I got arrested like
a year into doing it with uh my
ex-fiance at the time here in Austin
actually right down the street actually
I used to live down the street off 33rd
Street
sorry oops my bad so my bad well that's
cool he meant like 10 blocks away yeah
if you go down two blocks take a right
then take a left then you pass the yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it was a 10-year
Battle of trying to get off the ship I
want to say it's a battle man it was
just there's uh and this was back in
2010 and [ __ ] where it's like you know
people are a lot more uh accepting now
or it's like I think it's like I don't
think it I think because of like the
stigma and all the other [ __ ] that's
what made it take 10 years it wasn't
like
the addiction itself was a 10-year
battle plus you could be on brand for
comedy
sure yeah but you didn't do enough
because you're still here so yeah I'll
relapse yeah don't worry about that yeah
but what do you mean wait what do you
mean the stigma and stuff made it a lot
like you kept going back because the
world was still like you're a piece of
[ __ ] yeah a little bit so you're like
then I might as well be a piece might as
well own it yeah yeah and that's the
great thing about comedy is like you
know you kind of are a piece of [ __ ] on
you know not everybody is but it's like
an actor in here though and here you are
I mean I'm always a piece of student
here yeah but then you know it's a
little harder when Society puts that on
you and stuff and don't get me wrong
like I was a bit of a degenerate but
yeah
so it's not like it was like
you know shame on Society for that stuff
or whatever
can we talk about Donald Trump stuff
again
nowhere near as interesting as this man
you're addicted to drugs you had a deep
despair in your soul that you try to
fill with the more illicit of the drugs
where most people stop at a reasonable
Point yeah you're like let me just
abandon all hope yes no that is 100
accurate but the heroin feels that good
though right it does no because of all
the drugs you've taken it's it's solid
it's a really good I highly recommend it
I highly recommend trying it once at
least or do just do like an oxygon I
highly recommend the same thing I mean
it's not the yeah oh my God if you want
to go down that rabbit hole almost
everybody's kind of done here when like
Vicodin Dilaudid and even right same
family yeah all like there's so many
opiates so yes yes you know like
dramatically beautiful that this thing
that can make you feel so happy can also
destroy you yeah I think that's why they
called it heroin you know what I mean a
female you know it's like a lady that
the lady makes you feel so good she
ruins your life yeah yeah typical woman
am I right she is now the damn's on
distress yeah yeah now afternoon
have you seen uh am I right on Reddit
they did like a survey of all the people
that were like oh am I the [ __ ] no
he's like men are like 30 right women
are 70 right
yeah but I saw this like YouTube video
where like you know the crazy thing
about women is like they know 99 of the
time when their husband is cheating on
them
because the private investigator was
like 99 of time women are correct or
something ridiculous wow yeah and Men
it's like 50 50. like we have no idea
they're so sneaky they're so sneaky that
hidden ovulation you know what I mean
you never know but you can convince you
that we're actually not cheating on you
I mean that's why I just assume they're
always cheating that's why I'm just you
know you might as well or maybe that's
why 99 of women are right because they
always assume that like he's just
probably yeah
and you know just takes one search
through the phone unless you got like
some hardcore whatever player guy
that like uses Snapchat should you check
the phone of your significant other
no
if you feel like you have to there's
already a problem but isn't that most
relationships are having a problem yeah
no relationship is perfect no not even
close enough yeah so why could it why
wouldn't it make sense that your
insecurity takes a form of checking
their phone I think it's more subtler
things where it's like if you're like
reaching for the phone and then they
react a certain way then I was like
who's that yeah yeah I was at a pool and
this husband was like can you grab a
towel don't look at my phone okay
that's not what you do if if even I know
that you're cheating you're [ __ ] up
yeah I'm just a stranger if I'm a
stranger at a pool and I know he's
cheating on you buddy like what if you
have to yell at your don't look at my
phone don't look at it unless you're
really smart and you just always say
that where then it just becomes like a
joke yeah yeah don't look at my phone
she's like you silly goose you know I
was just
you do like one thing nice for and then
like that
then you can do it
yeah good advice guys if you're
listening do one nice thing one it only
takes one nice thing well wait wait
you've been cheated on yeah yeah oh bye
here actually no it was my first
boyfriend actually oh okay yeah now in
college uh yeah I
was very big on Don't Touch the phone
but also that was maybe he also called
his dick the phone the phone okay don't
touch the phone yeah you got to put your
ear to it yeah yeah well and it made
actually a lot of sense I think like a
month into the relationship I was like
oh your ex-girlfriend is sending you
nude videos of herself like masturbating
and then what'd he say and then he was
like yeah it's just it's comforting
really helps me get through the trauma
of that separation yeah that would have
been the first big red flag but he's
like yeah she's in Connecticut I never
see her it's fine like except for twice
a week when she sends me updates wait
what about keeping old nudes I hear
that's like a big No-No but I feel like
that should be fair game I know that's
what I think oh it's like what they sent
me like you know if but also if if
you're in a relationship and you're not
having intimacy with the person that
you're with and then she they like catch
you and you're like always off hiding
looking at the nudes of your right
that's a problem yes but also every now
and then yeah what a wonderful Memory
Lane to be like ah yeah College I was
talking to her about this the girl
version is looking at Old text which I
would like those to be deleted as a dude
if I have to delete the nudes kind of
deal I'm sure because how many nudes are
out yeah I'm shocked like I'm I'm late
to the game I'm 40 like the the real
phone and pictures and all that didn't
happen until I was like in my late 20s
when that even started yeah and it's
still shocking to be like
how willing people are to kind of say
news you're from the 20th century yeah
you know what I'm saying that same yeah
it's like it's crazy I think that's the
whole reason why Snapchat was invented
was just so you can send nudes and not
have to worry about them being safe
right yeah yeah and then everyone's like
ah forget it whatever
and now everyone's smart they just shoot
from the bottom lip down I've noticed
that you cannot see my face yeah I mean
I got it but yeah but also I have
tattoos but clearly identify I literally
have my name on my shoulder across the
shaft of my dick that's crazy your name
that's the word that's the weird one
yeah yeah actually I always thought it
would be interesting someone posted a
nude of themselves and then like
immediately got a bunch of tattoos then
could you deny it you're like that's not
me look I don't know clearly that is a
good girl move like someone's nudes get
Lee yeah like I have tattoos what are
you talking about because it's still
fresh and everything Mom and Dad that's
not me yeah yeah your face is clearly in
the picture that's not me
that person have a face tattoo of a
[ __ ] unicorn on their cheek
like that's a that's a little stick on
tattoo that's nice yeah it's like Hannah
a cheetah so you've been cheating have
you ever cheated
you never cheated
kind of means yes
when I was in rehab and then like we
haven't seen each other again and stuff
and yeah
like I felt a little bad but yeah yeah I
don't know did you hook up in rehab with
like another person of rehab or no if a
person from rehab but not in yeah just
right out of rehab that seems like it
would happen a lot you both went through
a lot you both are trying to be better
you're lonely yeah you're at a low Point
yeah
or you don't have your coping mechanisms
anymore which were the drugs and then
each other becomes a coping mechanism
yeah you find your other habit forming
thing that you got to find yeah yeah
Hans have you done a lot of drugs
uh
yes and no I've never cheated on anyone
ever
have you ever been cheated on
no not really what does not really mean
that's because we're in an open
relationship and it was messy what got
messy it's like are we in a relationship
right now or aren't we or am I allowed
to [ __ ] other people or not and she was
like no you're not but also I am
yeah sort of was it like that because I
don't know it depends on when the
timeline fits it's not really important
but yeah it's like a messy relationship
we were trying to cling on to it because
it was nice but there was no future in
it
but yeah let me get that what about you
yeah you've been cheated on yeah yeah
yeah a lot it was like you cheat on a
lot of people too yourself I've never
cheated I've never I can't I've it's a
weird thing because I've always I think
it's because I've been cheated like I
was cheated on this is
I've been cheated on by every girlfriend
I had from eighth grade through college
every single one
like cheated was that just one
girlfriend
we just kept getting back together
um no no it was
I mean does eighth grade relationships
even count I don't know we're making out
in touch with boobs okay okay
um yeah but I think it was like four or
five different women that all cheated on
me through that time Jesus so you had an
expectation of uh monogamy and they knew
that you had that expected yeah this was
the name bro this was the early 2000s
people the poly thing wasn't there yet
we weren't we weren't out there
no those people those people were 10 at
the time yeah yeah
um so yeah but it was like yeah like
you're my girlfriend we've been together
for two years and all of a sudden like
oh you've started [ __ ] some dude
um although because like when I was in
high school the thing was is you started
like in a relationship with someone the
day
like you'd be like I was like do you
want to go out we're going out what does
that mean I don't know
you're a monogamous so like everyone at
like my eighth grade girlfriend I was
with for like a year and a half
and then I got to I got to high school
and then then I was with another girl
for another almost year and a half and
then I was with the third girl in high
school for like two plus years and then
College I was with that that girl for
like almost did you have a question and
be like am I boring am I like not enough
no because once they cheat go [ __ ]
yourself like I'm out I'm not I'm not
you never took one of them back I've
taken them but you didn't notice one
yeah
not real I don't know
yeah you wanna know what the pattern was
I wasn't [ __ ] them
I had the weird thing where like I just
kind of put that on this pedestal of
like it's gonna be magic like it's gonna
be the most beaut like when doves when
the when the sun shines and doves fly
that's when you know it's when you
should put it in like in the entire time
I was a virgin the entire time that's
why and but like
like everything else was [ __ ] all the
time like
what do you mean like we were doing
everything but constantly okay okay
constantly so it wasn't like it was like
blow jobs oh yeah that's part of the
everything
yeah
you haven't lost it yet yeah yeah yeah
um wait were you religious no no no okay
no I just in my mind it was just this
thing that was like no that's supposed
to be so special and I just put it on
this pedestal of like I you know and
what's funny is I look back and it's
like literally not the eighth grade
girlfriend so much but like the high
school like those two and it's like oh
yeah they play [ __ ] they well they
probably I look back now and realize
like oh they were like ready
and I was like when we're ready when
we're and they're like I'm [ __ ] ready
no but I'm sure yeah
really believe the Bible hmm no it has
nothing to do with religion it had
nothing to do with religion or naughty
or anything I just that's changed my
mind I grew up on it was built up to be
like a very special thing and in my mind
but it's not like no once I had an ass
yeah
at age 20 when I did it for the first
time I realized I should have been
[ __ ] my high school girlfriends like
you should have stuck it in there yeah
yeah bro yeah um but I mean man that
would have been fun um but also you know
I didn't accidentally have a pregnancy
like I go back and forth on but I
realized like oh that's a bit because
they immediately literally like they
cheated on me by like screwing some guy
and then they were with that guy and
they were just off to the rabbit races
well yeah you don't want to be married
too young that's a trap yeah so by you
not [ __ ] people they actually [ __ ]
themselves because they're trying to get
you married
and it turns out that it just got you to
not get married because if you [ __ ] them
maybe you could have gone it wasn't a
marriage thing for me though it wasn't
like I wasn't waiting for marriage it
was just like I just thought it was
supposed to be something magically
special moment yeah
Jesus was gonna come down and tap me on
the shoulder and say enter the holy
Gates here
and we're all gonna that's the vagina
yeah I'm gonna touch you yeah
no it was horrible it was with one of
the gals that cheated on me but she just
like came around enough and she was
literally like kind of dating that dude
it's not even special at all then it was
it's horrible I know the whole thing you
broke it you're safe it was bad dude
yeah it's bad it's bad it was it was a
rough ride it was a rough yeah I've been
in therapy it's a thing okay okay fair
enough yeah so that's your heroine is
Unfaithful [ __ ]
laughs I love that [ __ ] that's my
[ __ ] problems
bad like not good not awesome but bad
can you turn that light off yeah the one
on top of the camera what do you think
can you pop that later because I think
that's what's making us not as on the
left side Orange
it's in the middle
so what do you think about the uh
still want to push down yeah off yeah uh
nice does that do it
no I still look like [ __ ] to be honest
let's just mind like something will
happen yeah
sex we've talked drugs
rock and roll rock and roll yeah
anyone all right Hans what's your
heroine we've got my hair oh yeah
My Heroine would have to be Settlers of
Catan we just saw that game yeah I was
just talking to her about that yeah I've
never played it before is it is it fun
it's it's fun it's strategic I'd be
crying
it's like a straight up cult like people
that are in the settlers container so
into it it's not that's I had fun you
put on the little robes and you put on
robes you like candles and you roll die
are you sure this is a witchcraft yeah I
think you're Wiccan
did you put a spell on somebody yeah
it's very hypnotizing the Simplicity
you've been playing a lot of that lately
no okay I'm sorry yeah okay okay who do
you play with like do you have a group
of comics that you play with or
civilians who sometimes yeah we played
yesterday with comedians but I play
online a lot oh [ __ ] I was like maybe I
like a tan for the friendships and then
I found it online and I was like nope
just the Katan
to find out that you've just been
playing Bots I mean they could still be
yeah you know they're programmed to say
racist things
that's pretty easy actually so uh Kenzie
what's your uh heroine oh yeah
Maybe getting new
huddling trying to learn new [ __ ] like
what what what's been in your list
answer thank you that was like a job
interview
as my desire to succeed I think it's I
think it's my desire to kill myself so
it's all like really Adrenaline Rush
kind of hobbies like what what are you
doing like uh skydiving was one for a
big while like you were just like doing
the tandem jumps or going to get your
Certification did you finish no I'm
still in the middle of it uh the problem
is you have to drive two hours to go to
it and so then you're there all day and
then um it's a full day and you can get
him a few jumps a day can you just jump
out at uh Austin Bergstrom because I
don't live in Austin ah who's that all
right so skydiving yes um scuba diving
is another one did you get certified
yeah I'm a Dive Master actually for that
one Dive Master Patty or what's it
called so I'm Patty SDI and then I just
transferred over to Maui as well nice so
you can go what the [ __ ] is Patty it's
uh they're just a certification company
in a way there's there's like it's like
boxing there's like 10 of them
yeah yeah it's an insurance thing it's
like kind of there's too many
certifications she's got a full binder
full of this [ __ ] that it's like because
anytime that you want to do anything
then you got to get a new serve for it
so if you want to go diving really deep
you got to get the Deep divers what's
considered deep 100 foot okay yeah yeah
you're when you get certified then
you're immediately able to go down to
60. you want to go more but hold on says
who says the dive boat that you then go
on like they get put the limits on you
you know this thing it's the insurance
policy so for the dive boats for the
company that certifies you so but if you
go on your own and have your own gear
you can do whatever you want right okay
I grew up in the Florida Keys so like
like I grew up in the water the first
time I had a tank on in the ocean I was
like six so like I just grew up doing it
and I never got certified because I have
older brothers and my dad they were all
certified yeah how can they regulate
that can you just buy it on Amazon yeah
you can buy your own beer and go if you
have a boat then that's the easiest
thing it's only for like if you're gonna
go with a dive group or a charge what is
the limiting factor is it the Crush
pressure is a big part yeah pressure in
time
well because it's time but if you have a
tank well so a tank will only last you
so long and then when the farther down
you go the more nitrogen buildup you
have in your system so you have to do
these safety stops on your way up and so
the longer you are down then the more
nitrogen buildup you have and you have
to get that out which is worse the
nitrogen or the gravity or the weight
the pressure uh the pressure you get I
mean because you're not I mean what's
the deepest you've gone
130 130 I think I think I've done I
think I've done 90. is it nitrogen or
the pressure
I mean so yeah you can definitely feel
it so you'll get something called
nitrogen Narcosis if you go dive down
too far too soon
um and that's that's it you just have
like such a buildup of nitrogen so I'd
say that's probably more so than
um pressure but that's if you have ear
trouble then more than the pressure will
sometimes mess with people more so it
just really depends I really hate that
feeling no I don't know actually you
would love that feeling no the pressure
it's like a white ear thing yeah it does
it does feel like the ocean's hugging
you I feel like it's like you know yeah
and it's like it's like just like a full
everywhere from every direction house
it's suffocating it's not hugging okay
it's it's clingy I don't yeah I want it
crazy about you it's because you're
carrying all that water above you yeah
so the deeper you know the more water
you're carrying above you and it's
pressing down on you and you're like
multiple atmospheres down so it's like
it's it's pressure it's legit yeah
that's so weird well so it's a scuba
that's one thing but free diving is
actually even worse because you
constantly have to be
um
clearing clearing and stuff but you're
also trying to do it quickly because
you're holding your breath you're
getting clear nitrogen how do you know
clear your pressure so you're like
holding and blowing and it kind of well
and so that's the valso have a maneuver
and so you're actually getting rid of um
the your breath while you're doing that
so most people do a thing called frenzel
which is really weird that you can make
your body do which is just pressing
forward
um on your sinuses and just releasing
that way yeah nice it's crazy and it's
super hard and deadly and people die
people die all the time oh yeah also
free diving too you do yeah from Freedom
yeah you free dive you like it though
you like at least the breath holds I do
enjoy the feeling of it dying this feels
like heroin yeah
uh no it's just like what's it called
the ma'am
dive reflex where it's like all the
blood leaves your hands and Limbs and
goes to your stomach preserve the organs
yeah yeah yeah so you do that on the
surface or like you go underwater and do
underwater I mean no we're doing it like
in a pool oh okay yeah just like laying
on the bottom and holding yeah
yeah
there's something about practice and
stuff so sometimes I'll join in and so
you do free dive then too yeah what do
you how deep you go there
um my lowest down I think it's been 80
foot which um it's [ __ ] legit it's
fun well and especially I need to
actually go back to Florida
um for a while there was trying to get
my instructor rating and be the only one
in
um there's really no instructors for
free diving in Dallas so can we talk
about heroin again no I love it this is
so interesting
but it was it was crazy like growing up
there my brother we all snorkeled and
we'd like Spearfish and my brother she's
got one he got a spear gun yeah dude
there's nothing more satisfying than
spearing a fish taking it to the surface
going and then 20 minutes later you're
cooking it up like there's something
about that uh but they're not what about
humans they stroke they fight it too
much you know they're heavy to get over
onto the boat that's true so it's a lot
I mean you don't they do eat a lotion
you can do it on land yeah but what's
the fun you know
um but I remember my brother got really
good at free diving and spear fishing
where he he got he would be able to and
there were all these tricks that guys
would do where like you hold one eye
shut so when you get to the bottom and
you open it and it's darker you your
eyes already adjusted and stuff but he
could work he could free dive down with
snorkeling mask and snorkel and Fit I
should say with fins oh yeah and he
could work 80 feet with a spear gun and
he I think he was like holding his
breath for like almost three minutes the
fish are like I should be safe here yeah
and then there's my brother just if I'm
going deep I'm not Britney Spear in my
spirit I will only bring that out if I'm
maybe going like 20 feet Yes like which
most of the time a hard time because
your ears the pressure yeah like at the
bottom of a pool I don't like to feel it
you can feel it like how do you even go
lower than this but I guess if it's like
that low you just eventually experiment
and find out yeah and you work on
learning how to clear and stuff like
that my brothers when they like a group
of them would go out and if they were
doing deeper water they would actually
snort Wasabi a little bit because it
just and then also you're just having
like a snot Fest for a few minutes but
they'd be out on the boat get all the
gear ready hydrate so and then they
would snort just a little bit and it
would just clear your sinuses completely
out everything's open yeah so it flows
through yeah that's a lot better than
what I would do if I'm going down to
Florida for a big week weekend or
whatever the case may be I then give up
Dairy for like two weeks just so you're
less congested and all that yeah yeah
and you're like [ __ ] that I want my
Dairy give me the Wasabi do mines
it's a good tip I'll try that is that
why Wasabi's with sushi
all right
I'm just saying because they're fish
where do you go in Florida
um this is our podcast
let's talk about something we've all
done before no but on the hobby she also
does wrestling piano it's ridiculous
piano the real the real depthifying your
heroin would be sugar oh I love sugar in
what form every form all the sugar sugar
all the time like the simpler the sugar
the better like elephant ears
dude a good elephant ear
the big thing that I've been doing
lately is I will buy a jar of frosting
and then I'll just take a couple
spoonfuls of it outside and then
frosting is so good this is pure sugar
so like like a peanut butter jar that's
what I used to testing for that's good
surprise you haven't started shooting it
up
is it got a spoon she's melting it in
the caramel yeah yeah I mean I
definitely taste it you shoot up you'll
[ __ ] really a little bit I guess I
could get a sugar stick and just snort
it yeah yeah I used to do that in
[ __ ] Middle School
I think so too probably good cocaine is
probably better for you than snorting
kids drop the smarties it's not where
the party's at you've got to be
responsible about these things
what hobbies have you had Hans what have
you what are you doing some of my
hobbies include podcasting yeah Settlers
of Catan yeah comedy Shiva what do you
think about the uh gun control laws uh
they're fantastic
they're like which one there's some
things that need to be fixed but there's
some good things about those guns it's a
very general wait a way to handle that
political move there yeah yeah mount
Shannon I believe in the good ones and I
uh disapprove of the bad ones and I
think we need to find a good middle
ground yes to really make sure
everyone's safe while free what do you
think about roads Hans
with a little bit smaller smaller roads
smaller roads
I think you need to build closer
together and then you won't need cars
maybe a couple bike Lanes on the
sidewalk not on the street did you get
this perspective after playing Settlers
of Catan so much that you're like you
know how to build roads now what should
we do with our Timber
um
well the thing is like
it's important to uh not have car based
infrastructure
yeah I mean that's the most of Europe
and stuff that was all designed by me
pre-car yeah and then here we actually
were like look at all this land and we
just spread everything out yeah are you
Pro trained then yes okay what about
planes I mean like just you can add on
them too
planes are cool because they don't have
to be on the ground it seems inefficient
that is true that is very true yeah
plants do not need to be open they do
have to be on the ground for a little
bit though yeah a little bit take off
and Landing yeah yeah they have to start
and stop on land but it's like there's
less friction up there
there's not a lot of human beings up
there there are
it's kind of terrifying when you see how
many planes
like they're still like it's a lot
better they're not close to each other
but how many people do you think are up
in the sky at once like tens of millions
millions yeah I think interesting
yeah let's go millions that could have
gone well tens of millions
maybe one million well what's the rush
hour for air traffic
I was thinking like 640 or something oh
much more than that oh
have you been to an airport and they're
just constantly Landing true true it's
like basically a train everything
becomes the same thing just it's just
like slightly different but airports
feel like train stations feel like bus
stations they're doing the same thing
yeah
settler of katante yeah what more do you
want it's a waiting room it doesn't have
to be something
what would you do to it oh no I have no
idea I would obviously be heroin yeah a
lot of people are missing their train
though maybe make it a library a library
waiting room
so all the books yeah combined I don't
like books books so that little children
reading books are right next to like
people pedophiles traveling by train
is that how they travel
so are they mainly the good ones and
then Ideal World pedophiles would travel
by train so you would outlaw them in
other capacity no planes no cars was
they are but you let them live but
you're like you've got to be on a train
though no not like that at all okay law
of averages so this doesn't totally
answer our question but it's something
that we can probably work with in 2019
4.5 billion passengers took 42 million
flights worldwide so that's an average
of 115 000 commercial flights every day
so 4.5 divided by 365 would give us per
day per day
well that's just commercial That's not
including anyone with a private plane
yeah which is negligible really oh well
yeah there's a like Farmers most of them
all have planes um like there's a lot
more stuff there's like yeah I want to
say there's okay oh okay there's like
something like 100 000 private pilots in
the country okay
for now
what was it 4.5 million but then also
it's per like at one time because some
of those are landing during the day or
whatever and stuff so so it's still 12
million a day
what okay 12 million people a day so
divide that by hour divide by 24. that
was way off and then divide that by
seconds to find it in one second
so it's 513 000 on average per hour yeah
but also the most flights like daytime
shifts around the world so we can't yeah
no no on the average yeah so half a
million people right now at least are in
the sky that's crazy half a million it's
a small country yeah yeah if earth goes
to [ __ ] you can just like hover and then
land and then they could repopulate
we're always safe we always got like a
few airplanes
preserving the world would have to go to
[ __ ] within like six hours like the
whole world would have to go to [ __ ] in
like six hours
I mean this could be a movie there are
people on the space station right that
preserves the negligible yeah okay maybe
maybe yeah you think they would be like
arrogant they'd be like well you came
from the air we came from space Oh yeah
I'm sure there's a hierarchy there or
it's like you're a pilot like uh dude
I'm
also though they have like can they this
does the space station have like
emergency capsules can they just get out
if they want to doesn't somebody have to
go there and bring them home I believe
the ladder you imagine if they just
watched the world disappear and they
just know they're like well we're here
as long as we can keep making oxygen
I would be cool with that
you have to see the world end to see the
show from above the whole thing they
don't have a life raft no life raft also
like
just like a propeller like the scuba
divers use just like a just get into
Earth I'm sure that will be a thing or
they do that with astronauts they got a
little little jet packs but those can't
bring you into the atmosphere they can't
probably destroy that you're like really
hot oh that's how they do it yeah
there's no more Atmos you just gotta go
through the hole in the ozone yeah you
just gotta find it super easy yeah
anyway
you can do it hold your breath dude
clear your nose
also though if you were to make it back
what would you be making it back to yeah
there's nothing there's no reason you're
gonna die when you land you're gonna die
on re-entry or you're just gonna die in
the space station yeah good land yeah
although I think it would be sad uh than
being in the Mesa space station because
there's no alcohol
is going to end like you can make it if
you can make it important they're
literally space
scientists chemists and physicists they
might be able to pull it off they
probably can yeah I would start Breaking
Bad up there just start making math up
there and just [ __ ] go phase out yeah
we get it you're in the drugs
James would start dating women that
cheat on them with the only other person
in the space station well I mean you
know she's gonna have to cheat if we're
gonna repopulate the planets yeah I
would sleep with him there's no one
which I'm not gonna do so it's not a
problem
wait are you in a relationship now no
okay interesting interesting that's uh
I'm uh uh I got out of my second divorce
uh about three years ago okay and now I
have a kid so I have a five-year-old
daughter which makes dating like if I'm
trying to like have a comedy career and
raise a kid 50 of the time yeah I don't
it's the heart it's this it sucks it's a
lonely kind of existence in the sense of
like I've met I've gone on like a couple
of dates recently yeah and they went
well and they were nice and like I dug
her and we had a great time and then it
was like at the end of the day I was
like I'd really like to do this again
and she was cool like when are you
available and stuff and I like pull out
my phone I'm like I have a Wednesday
lunch we could do a month and a half
from now yeah yeah because like if I
don't have my kid I'm doing shows and if
I have my kid I'm not going on a date
never out you're never in the same place
for a long time you're always like
traveling I'm just I don't even travel
much for coming it's just either local
I'm either with my kid or doing just
bring it to a comedy show yeah uh I
don't know if you've been to a comedy
club but not the most conducive for
five-year-olds especially considering
wait is it date five years old oh that's
who you might bring because I I know
every this is my take and I'm pretty
sure it's real every comic hates one
another comic brings their girlfriend
yeah because we're like what are you
doing okay now I have to be nice to
someone I'm not even gonna [ __ ] and
isn't funny yeah isn't gonna do anything
for me actually my buddy told me the
best roundabout way of doing that go to
a big show that you're not on
take a date to a show that you're not on
because then it's like you get all the
validation because all the comics know
you and the bartender knows you and
stuff you have none of the pressure of
having to perform and do well you know
what I mean because I don't want I'd
rather be on a show somewhere else his
problem is that he doesn't have time
outside of Comedy so or kids yeah yeah I
mean the raising a kid or doing shows do
a show once and just hang out with your
date I'm saying go to the same show
you're still there and then yeah maybe
when she was the bathroom dude guess
about it I don't know I bring my dates
to all my shows do you really yeah like
as David that guy yeah
like do you go to like Hey we're gonna
go to dinner and then go to a show or is
the date your show well I tell them it's
a show that I'm on but it feels like a
show
and it's like a heightened social
environment yeah or you're a king you
get to go on stage and shine no that's
awesome
you are but sometimes I bomb but it
doesn't really matter how I do on stage
because your your demeanor changes in no
way whatsoever
yeah it's like is he happy when he gets
off stage he can't tell whether it's a
good song
why would you tie your emotions up into
something so you know you should like be
completely independent
and if good if you feel good you should
feel good I I get that but you're just a
hard person to read are you saying that
when you have a bad set it doesn't
affect you in any way whatsoever no I
say like it doesn't affect the date as
much unless I bomb horribly yeah I feel
like it would affect the date either way
because I mean if you do really really
well then she's like great you didn't
make like that's I don't know well she
doesn't want to be on a date with like a
guy that sucks yeah
but
um I think like if you haven't you know
get her in the bag before you can bring
her to the show and then you don't have
to worry about it if she likes you then
actually I use online dating sometimes
to get people to show
what's funny about that is I've seen
guys do that I've been at shows where
some guy went on like there was like six
different women in the audience that all
thought they were on a date with that
guy yeah see I don't do that
like he was like yeah come hang out say
and then I saw him kind of like maneuver
back like then talk to them each after
the show what's this guy's name I like
this guy I forget
I can't remember who he was but it stuck
in my mind I remember sitting in the
back of the room and like it came up
during the show like someone else's set
because like during the show he said
something and someone else was like oh
who hears from match or something or who
da da and some girl was like oh I I'm
I'm with the comedian guy and he was
like well wait then who wait you said
you were with some like who are you with
she's like I'm waiting another comic
like like blew the whole thing off on
stage that's hilarious it was like wait
you and then like is anyone else and
there was like four other girls and they
were all there to meet him after the
show they go on stage yet yes he had
already done a set so he didn't yeah
that would do well
um well yeah he brought six people yeah
I mean there were there were 12 people
at the show he brought half the car no I
think there was more than that but it
was it was weird I I don't remember what
they did well I don't think he was a
great comic but it was like a bringer
show mentality like it was it was a
bringer show and uh I think that's only
exception if you're new to Comedy and
doing a show and pull that stuff
disrespect for the people that you're
trying to date he's like these are just
people that I can use yeah I don't think
he was trying to date them no I don't
know but he was in that Arena profound
disrespect what you're doing to the
people that you're trying to someone's
looking for love what I do is different
because I'll post like a fire on online
dating and I'm like if you want to come
to the show you can but like it's like
PS maybe I [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it's like
we are not on a date but you can come to
the show and come hang out let me see
let me see the [ __ ] let's have it on
right now and it's not a message it's
like I literally posted on the thing
yeah I mean a lot of the same people or
a lot to the same show I think it's a
little
yeah it's like oh like that's what you
do to people that's how you use them how
many would you get
at most I've probably got capitalism not
many I'm not pulling the same people
he's pulling apparently
what do you think about capitalism
I think it can be done properly uh it
just hasn't been done
I think traditionally it's taken
advantage of a lot of people but it's
also built a lot of opportunity
don't you think it's like a progression
and we should keep going from feudalism
to capitalism to the next thing and
we're just stuck on this one method of
doing things I think that's changing
though now with the with the internet
though that's really brought
a lot of whatever like capitalism's
foibles or whatever yeah I like I I know
a group of people like they kind of
specialize in like uh they do they have
a consulting firm for like conscious
capitalists and I'm like there's a way
to do this right there's a way to pay
your people there's a way that like
to you know you look at you know
everyone whatever but Jeff Bezos like
why do we have to preserve the old
system have you designed the new one yet
well how what do they design it during
feudalism capitalism I don't know so
what do we need just pure chaos until
somebody the same thing that our
founding fathers did and instead of just
going along with the old wealth
distribution making a one that actually
works and to use capitalism and be like
we can do it but why like why should we
I feel like that's kind of naturally
happening though because I think because
of the internet people are aware that
like oh these companies are [ __ ] bag
companies I'm gonna choose to do
business with better companies I'm going
to research the the products I use and
choose more direct small town local
granted the shitty companies are on to
that and now it's just all about image
right what I'm saying but also we can
see through that better than ever yeah
yeah yes I know I feel like well also
there was a report that I just read that
like ubereats for example some people
like during the pandemic people were
like oh I'm buying local when in reality
it was just oh you're buying from
7-Eleven but they will go by a different
name right or whatever the case is
interesting yeah so there's that they're
hiding stuff in there I'm all for a
better system but we don't have one yet
I'm cool with that attitude
I'm just drifting through the wind right
now that's that's it I got my own [ __ ]
to deal with I like how you're trying to
take on the whole world's problems yeah
that's uh it's very well with you why
not like why why not go for the big one
if we're gonna talk about anything it's
all meaningless do you have any ideas
though do you have any is there um he
wants to get rid of the road that's what
I think that
you need to have
stronger unions
uh universal healthcare some things the
private Market can't do like low income
housing and health care I don't think it
should be for-profit
um yeah
and
just uh you get paid what you bring in
like if a McDonald worker makes a burger
and that brought in like 40 of the 239
and it gets 40 percent of the 239 well
that's not how business works I mean
like you still have to pay another
Burger
well if it is 40 of the profit whatever
the number is right now it's the minimum
amount possible Right what is the least
amount I can give you and I think it
should be more percentage whatever that
is maybe not 40 maybe like
ten maybe two instead of an hourly wage
it's just whatever you serve your
product yeah whatever you bring in
you're worth your production yeah
instead of just the top guy taking as
much as possible yeah that's I mean
that's how it works yeah right I feel
like anyone though with eight like eight
that needing ADA compliance or something
like that would definitely have a
problem with that though like yeah
disabilities acts no one would have to
what do you mean well because like um
like for example if you work in a
certain company then you have to make
certain adjustments for people with
disabilities right and so if it's all
based off of productivity and there's
someone that only has like let's say one
hand and can only do half of whatever is
the you know it's probably not the right
person for that job you would assume but
in the in today's society they still
have the job yeah well you would also
just give them uh housing and food off
the bat um
but that lady with no more makes stuff
with her feet like she has to like I
don't want her making my Burr
unfortunately I don't know
she doesn't have to I in their world it
seems like wow you know people aren't
even going to be making Burgers yeah the
robots are going to be here in no time
you've got a burger made by a person
that's gross
yeah that will be another woman that
will be the new Norm yeah yeah just
metal
or it'll be like it it Cooks it while it
takes it
slices the tomato
I mean I think like uh a lot of the
problems in the world are like you know
like the only thing that we have to
fight is ourselves we have all the
technology we have all the time the only
thing that can defeat us is ourselves I
think like yeah we're not fighting the
Nazis we're not fighting you know the
Great Blizzard or whatever
like the white walkers are dead yeah
we're still fighting each other though
yeah yeah but again it's mainly over
resources and control yeah I mean Comics
fight each other every day I feel like I
feel like yeah
there's always some sort of drama or war
going on I feel like yeah are they good
Comics some of them sure a lot of them
know that's objective what like sorry
what scene did you come out of so I'm
I'm in the Dallas scene now Dallas scene
where where did you start I started in
Wichita Kansas okay
and was the like I started in San Diego
and when I got there like the class
before us it was very much like people
were in a weird way like sabotaging each
other and stuff like that and then my
group got there which was like Derek
Hassan
uh Brian was there and it was like all
sudden it was like this class of love
where we were just like we clicked with
each other we were supportive we were
helping we were building each other up
and like it was like this beautiful like
family and people would tell us like
this is not how most scenes are man like
and even the guys there were like the
guys that were older than us like they
didn't like us because we were like that
yeah and they were from you know they've
been doing it five years already yeah
you guys all left are you still there
I'm still there because my kid's there
um and I love San Diego gotta get rid of
that kid dude yeah this kid is cropping
up a lot
yeah she's almost five I don't think I
don't think I can't take the
five-year-old take her to Oregon yeah
Oregon it's legal
you can drug her up on mushrooms and
then shoot her in the head okay oh my
God yeah
but like was your scene loving or all
like
uh in Wichita I think it was more loving
towards me because I was one of like
maybe five females so starting out there
by loving you mean it was awkward
because everyone was trying to have sex
with you there's that but also just
there was one one
um woman there who she's moved on I
think she's in Colorado now but she died
she's on the other side she moved on to
a better life I just remember that she
saw me go up on the open mic and
immediately was like okay woman you were
and like book me on my first show day
two which is crazy
getting opportunities because they're
women it's easier
and now I'm struggling yeah yeah
yeah and then what about where'd you
start Dallas in Dallas what was that
scene Like Loving uh they hated me and
with right yeah I was on drugs and it
was a little understandable uh and then
now it's kind of like the same thing
kind of happened I mean we are still or
maybe it's just me but there's still a
little competitiveness to it but but
yeah like the people that in my class or
whatever be like Lawrence Rosales and
like
[Music]
and I'm super competitive with that
[ __ ] it is it is funny though
they had a shirtless competition at the
last open month well he was trying to
say he's more attractive and I was like
uh-ish and then you both took your
shirts off and everyone was like neither
of you were attracted yeah that
basically happened
I mean are you most of the time you're
wearing a shirt you should judge your
attractiveness wearing a shirt I guess
they wanted to see more of your body you
know more how much more interested
Lawrence kept holding people who's more
attractive he's like we should take our
shirts out there like nobody wants us to
take it no we should do we did mention
it first and then I was like really and
then I was like [ __ ] yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] ten minutes he's like no I think
you know what I don't think they can see
enough we got to take our pants off dude
we're good we're getting there we're
getting there I think next round it'll
be it will be what about you when you
started what was the vibe like towards
you towards in the scene was it loving
was it supportive was it good they were
like holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
why did you say that what did you say
like the Jews
wait aren't you from Seattle right
originally yeah yeah that would make
sense why are we worshiping the Jewish
religion like they have the worst luck
why would we worship Jesus like you know
they don't worship Jesus yeah they don't
they don't in Seattle
Jewish people in general no no like why
would we adopt a Christian religion from
the Jews like the other words like why
would we worship Jesus when like the
Jewish god is probably like the worst
God and this was a bit this was yeah
there's a punch line here that's the
punch line and so so that's was that
like your open mics kind of stuff no and
then they're like what are you doing
well no I think some people are like
yeah that's true like why do we worship
a Jewish religion right but were you
starting your own cult or doing open my
comedy that's the part I I'm like well
it's just like an observation it's like
why Judy it what an accident of History
what a hilarious mistake we all made
your comedies come a long way yeah I'm
gonna be honest you're very funny now
you have to like judge the Merit of the
joke just like that's the subject matter
that was said got it and then and you
were being done anyway based on that
yeah it was like a fun time uh they were
just sort of shocked by me
uh and then because of what you were
saying yeah which is understandable yeah
I mean you're going for it I mean that's
yeah yeah it's gutsy premise like so so
but was I mean once you kind of
something like Eddie Izzard saying it or
like you know how he does the British
you know the British took over whatever
or Mark Norman makes fun of Jews all the
time actually I heard it is he Jewish I
don't know no okay that's what I thought
okay okay but anyway so it's like your
first bit that you did oh it was
terrible how did the scene except you
and wherever you a lot of them left and
then I started working at the uh
comedy club which helped a bit and I
don't I mean a lot of it was like
good timing because I started in 2015
where it's like there was this big rush
instant like a this is after like Louie
and stuff so a bunch of people there was
like a wave of comedians wanting to do
that and stuff and I came at the right
time where it was like we got probably
like 50 new I mean probably only like 10
of us or still hear from that or
whatever in that whole year and then
when kovid yeah yeah yeah no it's like
Ralph Barbosa you know there's some
people that were like kind of the class
ahead of me that I might be confusing
towards mine but
but yeah I mean it just took time and
patience and people got to know me and
I'm not I think I'm a piece of [ __ ] but
I'm not the biggest piece of [ __ ] and
yeah people just accepted me a little
bit and you know it's I mean same thing
with you I mean you still do crazy
premises but people know you now where
it's like more they're more willing to
accept your yeah I mean the community
here is really nice to me so that's nice
and other people that aren't nice
you know they can go [ __ ] themselves
right but yeah New York didn't really
accept me I was bombing it in the open
mics which I I enjoyed because I think
you learned something through open mics
it's like a grit and sort of like trying
to make the most depressed people happy
I think it's
I think it's a worthwhile thing to do
and I think there's some great moments
and open mics
um but yeah and then to Seattle I
started out kind of rough that's where I
started out and then like towards the
end of it I was getting booked a lot so
that was good nice but so once but like
was the scene once they kind of got to
know you like you showed up and shocked
the hell out of him it sounds like
because they were like yeah they just
like you were just touching the subjects
and doing stuff but like once they like
got to bore you with my
stupid jokes no no no no no no
but like I was in the open micro like
that's you're pushing hard that's like
that's yeah that's not there the joke
there is hard to make yeah the
observation is there but like where to
find the funny in it and stuff like that
that's true then they show up in a scene
and do that and be trying to find your
feet and find you know find the jokes
within it it was difficult at times
right
trying to say this most shocking things
yeah and so did they like like once they
kind of got to know you did they like
you know bring you in and it was like a
positive thing and and you know grew
together they could you know because I
was autistic and they were
Seattle you know uh Seattle freeze you
know weirdo theater Majors that are
bitter at the world and jocks and that's
who was doing the open minds yeah okay
it's very interesting
poetry-esque Vibe but there is a lot of
like dudes that are like gross and
stupid there too it's a nice balance
but yeah I I enjoyed that scene I was a
part of that scene I'm proud to have
been part of that scene uh
yeah and then New York I was proud to be
there you know they didn't really accept
me but I I enjoyed the time there I
think it made me tougher and more uh
better at comedy at a more rapid Pace
than any other City
and then I love Austin because like
I'm doing awesome
this is the best it's ever been so I'm
gonna chill here for a while nice that
makes sense what
um how long like once you got here how
long did it take you for to really find
your footing here I got here in March
like 20
second and then I became a kill Tony
regular mate 30 or June 6th so that's
like of this year three months no uh
last last year
and then also remember on kill Tony
before though right yeah I was on kill
Tony a bunch yeah yeah and now you do it
like when you say regular like you're
every single week or yeah
thanks
yeah and then do you yeah I'm getting
it's a brand it's a new one minute every
time right yeah
and then do you practice that minute
elsewhere you just go in with a brand
new practice it I sometimes don't
practice it I usually practice it I
don't want to say online for the first
time a joke yeah but sometimes I have to
because sometimes it's like a lot of
like when you're going about to go up on
a comedy show it's like you're like what
do I feel like saying today it's like
what kind of convincingly think is funny
and sometimes it's slim pickings on a
Monday sure
do you hate do you hate doing that
minute or do you love it or hate love I
hate not doing that minute well okay I
hate the pressure that one bothers you
that one box seed yeah because it's
online I see everyone sees it it's like
a public open mic yeah
but it's like something that I wanted
yeah I watched the show I'd be like oh
man if I was in that position I'd be
writing all these new jokes I
gotta write all these new jokes yeah
yeah
well and all of them are I'm assuming as
great as the Jewish Jesus joke
you should try that first joke again
you're a better comic now you can
probably do something with it well yeah
you guys really shook my confidence
tell me is it was it hard or is it hard
for you like like one minute is not a
lot of time I mean that's my biggest I
we would go to La every now and then
from San Diego and I had friends that
had done kill Tony when it was there and
I remember like are you signing up I'm
like no I can't like I'm and I'm more of
like Storyteller talk about things so
I'm just way too many and I'm like I
have nothing to do in a minute I just
don't yeah so it was a lot of it's uh
the interview though I feel like
interview is important yeah joke joke
writers are definitely favorite on the
show
um yeah it's like all about being a cool
person or like you know just like going
with the flow and you know wait so how
did you get it then I don't know
I have no idea
uh but uh you know it's fun I'm working
on it it's a good time uh but yeah like
the interview is important
uh but
yeah the set's also important I don't
know you should do it I think like you
could find some jokes you could do just
say your story faster
I thought about it just like sound like
the Micro Machines guys yeah
because how many jokes do you get out in
a minute three okay if they're good
because you have to wait for all the
people to sit down and stop I'm doing
good I do get two jokes okay one once I
got one out when I was planning for
three I was like oh thank God so you got
one out and then it was just a great
response and then just by then it was
time up yes that's beautiful yeah got
two more jokes for next week yeah and if
I tell them right yeah I'll do the third
one the week after that maybe that's on
myself just one really good joke every
week and then that's it
but this time it's gonna be really good
yeah have you ever gone back on and been
like ah they don't remember this one and
done one again no no oh yeah what about
originally when you first because now
it's like you've been uh a regular yeah
you got to come up with a new minute but
like when you first were starting out
you never repeated jokes when you redid
kill Tony no okay okay how often did
those jokes end up in your act like do a
lot of them or all of them or the good
ones or is it like some of them just end
up on kill Tony and that's it about 20
15 it's pretty good actually yeah yeah I
mean what a way to generate material
yeah yeah I mean it definitely motivates
me to generate material but I also just
do more of what I was doing anyways it's
not like I'm doing anything Jewish jokes
more different I'm just doing more of it
yeah
what do you think about the Jews
uh very shitty people uh no no uh she I
think you're half Jewish right yeah
mother father mother
mother's Methodist all right she's
Methodist now but the Heritage was it's
over there just like a Jew yeah
yeah I think they got something going
right I mean there's no hell
every
uh they're rich
not all of them there's poor juice
um but like I grew up my family grew up
with a Jewish family we were just really
close with and they had daughters the
same age as my older brothers and we
like traveled in the Summers together
and like they did all the Christian
holidays with us we weren't like
religious but we did the holidays kind
of stuff okay and we did in the same
boat like they were Jewish but it was
more cultural than religion and so we
did all like Passover and Hanukkah and
Yom Kippur and all that with them and it
was kind of nice that like we got to see
it all and do it all but like I remember
growing up and being like over here with
the stuff my grandma talks about there's
hell and there's sin and there's all
this horrible [ __ ] and then over here at
our Jewish friend's house there's no
hell what kind of Christian Catholic
yeah okay well yeah yeah yeah okay
that's the worst kind yeah but it was
still like we're like the Jews every
religion every religion revolves around
food family and there's no hell like
it's in as low levels of fun I don't
dude
if you're super Orthodox yeah but if
you're reformed then yeah you're fine
and on a lot of things well I guess uh I
mean Christians have Christmas
calves the Jews have like Hanukkah good
they smell a little gift
eight nights of gifts though yeah yes
not everyone gets a dreidel every night
like it's not just I'm assuming it's
every night a dream I'm assuming it's
just the same just a different color
Drake I'm assuming they take back the
dreidel and then give it back to them
because they're Jews you know what I'm
saying no all right also Hanukkah is not
even that big of a like you're not
enjoying this
you got a lot of Jewish fan bait you got
a big Jewish fan base I I don't know
okay okay I don't know he does now I
don't now we can change it yeah
I love all the people that's the biggest
part is like I don't care what you are
it's that easy no I agree with that no I
totally agree with that but that's why I
don't like it when some people are like
these people's traumas it's like it's
all subjective right right it's everyone
has their experience yeah and like I
know what I look like I was dealt in
this country the best hand of cards you
could be dealt from the beginning like
as far as walking around ruin it with a
beard and long hair and a five-year-old
kid
but it's you know but again we all wake
up and sometimes that's hard to get
through that day and I can't imagine
what someone else's experience is and
I'm you know I understand the fortunate
existence I've had where I don't have to
wake up and remind myself that like oh I
look like this and the world treats
people that look like this different
mind my day yeah like you're not Jewish
but a lot of Jews can pass
a lot of Jews are like saying they're a
minority but it's like oh I get what
you're saying are you like anti-juice
yeah
I didn't tell them you're half Jewish
though so if some white guy was like
yeah I'm Jewish I'll be like yeah but
you don't have to deal with any of the
negatives like gay people it's like you
don't have to tell people or something
it's like gay people it's like you can
hide your sexuality yeah why don't you
hide you hide your sexuality more gays
through two out in the open about it
I'm trying to put mine out there
you're getting this out no but I'm not
fully gay I'm bi but yeah everyone's bad
no so you're right so you're a woman
okay you're just a young woman yeah
exactly I've seen women too I get it I
get it yeah
actually I do like that
well that's why I'm trying to put it out
there
what's what's your favorite joke that
you like recent joke that you've written
like what's it
like when was the last time you wrote a
really good one that you like
uh one that comes to mind is a nice one
about Asians and race
no wow wait a second Asians go on so how
did it come about well yeah don't say
the bit but like how did it come about
what inspired it and what do you was in
The Green Room at the Vulcan okay and
someone was said panic attack
and I was like panic attack and then I
said the punchline which I'm not gonna
say okay
are you saying Hispanic attack
no I've heard that joke I've heard that
I don't want to ruin the punchline no
not for me okay okay listen there are
nine people watching oh my God no no
don't say [ __ ] [ __ ] I wanted it to
be a secret maybe don't say it just for
you guys even but wait was that it
should be mine was that the punch line
this should be My Prerogative to reveal
it
that's a great guess that wasn't it okay
okay then I don't feel bad yeah no that
was a great guess oh and then it wasn't
that was the punch that was a great
guess okay
but not the punches it's not the
punchline that was a great guess okay
add it to the bit now yeah but yeah
that's a good test it's just like a
stupid thing but I guess everything's
stupid if you think about it it's about
the context got it yeah
um but yeah I mean it's a fun time when
just hanging out with the comics in the
green room and they said something and
nobody laughed and then I was like I'll
show you guys then I said it on stage
and I say it every night and it's a
reliable laugh so nice what about you
what's something what's a reason
uh
one that's been working oh I have a good
astrology joke that's been working
yeah yeah how'd that come about blood
inside I was dating a lady that was into
astrology and dating a 23 year old yeah
that's problematic was it yeah when is
it okay then 25 like yeah give them a
chance I did two years after 21 and yeah
and it's not like I'm aggressive what 23
is yeah yeah
she was chasing you yeah yeah it was
Mutual yeah nice yeah I'm not that
agreed I'm not an aggressive dude like
I'm not like hey well don't you think
girls sometimes mature faster than men
and they need yeah yeah and I'm immature
as [ __ ] so for a 23 year old that's Pro
because they say once you start doing
drugs that your emotional
like that's it you're locked in there no
not locked in but until you get sober
and like start feeling your feelings
again so you wrote a joke about her
because she was stupid
I wouldn't put it like that but yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
or it wasn't even about it wasn't even
calling her stupid uh it was uh turns
into a sex joke that's just a stupid sex
joke but it works well and it's like
recent like yeah two months three months
yeah what about you and you uh
I've been working on some good stuff
um I have one about out well so I was
recently diagnosed with ADHD so I've
been talking about that a lot on stage
and that's how it came about because I
was diagnosed with ADHD
were you in their feelings about this
yeah
were you in therapy in the in the
therapist no well uh no I I actually
sought out a psychiatrist to be like hey
I was told this might be a reason or a
thing to check out what do they give you
Adderall nice do you have any I do
should we
[Laughter]
do you like you like Adderall uh I have
I don't have a lot of experience with it
but I like that he loves Adderall
there's no food you're so bored with
Adderall you're just studying something
man we have endogenous Adderall pumping
through our veins
I only did it a couple times in college
and I was like this is not good like
this is we do I did it a couple times to
study and one time I like oh like not
OD'd but I took definitely took too much
because I just got to the point where I
was like we're [ __ ] like all sudden I
was like it doesn't matter what we study
it doesn't matter the test is in two
hours we're just [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
that's it yeah
um and my problem is I'm normally very
hyper focused on like a lot of stuff so
whenever I take Adderall it's like Oh
I'm a regular person now this is nice
it's so weird what studying is the
concept of studying you're just staring
at a book reading the words and then
you're picturing it you're like oh
picture it stop picturing other things
and then just like it later yeah you
have to live in a material hope it
sticks it's just a ritual it's like
meditation it's like humble yourself
child here is physics
and then you study fluid dynamics and
like you're like oh water if it's
laminar flows this way but it's
turbulent there's another equation you
need
anyways I think school was fun no I
hated schools how did you learn to study
because I realized that when I got to
college like oh nobody I don't know how
to study like do you just read the book
because that doesn't [ __ ] work yeah
so I'm like like I like how did you
learn to study and I mean it was a very
result result
based where it's like let me just try to
do good on the test let me just do
problems over and over again until and
then like figure out what I need to know
for the problems and then like go
through like the part where they teach
you about it if you have to but not try
not to do that
because then it'll take forever I was
gonna say just get parents that make you
study that just force you in your room
I guess to me it was like like so just
read it over and over until you can
recite all of it my thing was more math
so a little different and spelling bees
and I don't know about you all but when
I was in school it was all multiple
choice so like even if I didn't know an
answer I'd be like great see done
because Kansas yeah that's why yeah well
because he's the most illogical Choice
like it's and when you look at the
middle what it's going to be yeah C is
generally the answer this is not the
second one
down
rule of three yeah nice
comedy what was your latest bit that you
've been doing
um
I have I uh I talk about that date the
like the first date I kind of went on
and then uh and just dating and jump
yeah uh and just dating in general like
I'm on hinged now and that's like new
and different a lot of married people at
lunch by the way I've been told I've
seen a lot of women are like I'm married
but looking for like a play person or
like if I'm we're open and uh that's
what she said yeah [ __ ] is awesome
and we should be doing more of it
especially just one person forever
it's unrealistic it's not
you can just like do it for a while and
then sign paperwork and then that's not
all of now I'm at an age where all of my
friends now are getting married and I'm
like this is great but it's a lot the
stress don't worry they'll get divorced
in a few years they should start having
like divorce parties well ideally you'd
be with someone who gets you and then
every now and then you'd be able to [ __ ]
yeah a supermodel sure because I don't
know or just that lady at 7-Eleven it
doesn't have to be a supermodel it could
just be something oh yeah totally but
that's like the list that you're able to
do when you're um it's generally
celebrities but yeah yeah who's on your
list well there's this gal at 7-Eleven
what well I thought we were talking
about celebrities honey she's like no I
have low expectations she's a celebrity
to me yeah yeah yeah it's like oh this
is actually attainable this is kind of a
problem now
yeah
that's fun
sex is fun I enjoy it do you guys uh
ever just have sex and then you're like
I did it the wrong way I should have
done it the more pure way and instead I
feel guilty pure way yeah what is what
is the power condoms never oh God is
that what you mean is that what you mean
no I bet just like the chase or the hunt
was you know there was something that
you wish that you did as opposed to just
like I suppose meeting and immediately
being a douchebag and channeling your
inner
Jersey Shore it's been like wanna [ __ ]
but if they say yes then I mean as long
as everyone's on board
is it I mean yeah yeah for sure but I
mean like like they're like you know if
you meet them and just immediately
there's Vibe and you're like do you want
to go [ __ ] and they're like I'd love to
go [ __ ] and then you two people go do
the fun [ __ ] is that not yeah that's
ideal but yeah has it ever happened
where that idea didn't happen and you
felt kind of bad or weird about it as
what's the non-ideal I don't get what I
don't get where we're missing like
people still like as opposed to what
like uh maybe you actually don't really
respect her and you have sex with her
and then she's just like you're annoyed
with her and then why do you have to
respect them to have sex with them now
exactly I mean you don't have to but
it's not ideal I think that's just
called being a douchebag
wow let's face it you're chasing someone
yeah that's what I'm saying too yeah
like it's mutual if you're both are like
we're just here for that's one situation
another situation is you're chasing
someone and they actually and they think
they're being chased and then they're
doing like a favor to you and having sex
with you and then it's like that then
you feel kind of weird about that is
that a thing but I don't think I've ever
had one favor sex yeah how do you know
that it's famous it's the only sex I
have well sometimes I do feel it it's
weird that you ask a friend can you do
me a favor listen the real easy favor
yeah yeah
if someone's asking that I just feel
like they'd be the type of person be
like can you give me an orgasm is that
yeah and I can try I can try yeah I just
need a favor I just need this you look
like you need a back rub and buy back I
mean [ __ ] like is it or do the back rub
on top of it yeah start there start
there yeah yeah I like it
so I guess yes
I have the power of empathy and the
ability to imagine how did you get that
positive and negative radiation falling
just positive things okay but I think a
lot you know because like there's been
really good relationships I've had where
there were
uh it was overall positive but there
were still you know I think I think
every time you have sex there are going
to be some negative feelings
yeah everything that interesting I'm
just like hey that could have gone
better or I wish I would have stretched
first or something or it was like maybe
I wish she would like me more or I wish
I liked her more or you know just you
know I think sometimes when I first was
having sex I'd be like this is the most
awesome thing I could be doing right now
complete opposite of his perspective
so that's like kind of a weird thought
to have during sex where you're like I'm
doing it
you know is that like a virtual high
five for yourself like yeah we did well
it's weird it's because like this is
supposed to be awesome like this it is
to be awesome yeah and sometimes I've
definitely had those moments in my head
where like I can't believe this has
happened right now I have other thought
or like I'm doing the coolest thing I
could be doing right now nobody is
having a better time than me right now
once definitely not her
one time years ago I got caught in mid
mid act and I I looked at the clock and
she thought I think she took it and she
saw me kind of like glance over and she
took it as in I looked at the clock to
be like is this like how long is it
right and I looked at the clock going
holy [ __ ] 34 minutes this is fit this is
like my personal record like this is
amazing like you're killing it right now
and it was such this miscommunication
and I like looked at glance and I felt
great and she saw me glance and she like
I guess I didn't look at the clock is
always self-judged it's such a
misaligned look yeah that look is you
know everyone shits on that look but
it's not just one meaning if you have
multiple I'm having my experience over
here and uh but I felt that because I
think she legitimately felt bad like I
was like bored well what happened after
we went for another 15 minutes and I
think she changed her mind okay there
you go yeah yeah well let's see almost
in that sense where it's like that was a
negative feeling but the overall thing
it's not a positive experience yeah we
did it the next day so it hadn't been
you know if you're having sex with
someone and she's like that was the best
sex I've ever had but to you it was just
like that was nice do you like tell her
like yeah no calm your tits or are you
just like that was because then if you
don't tell her you misalign and then
you're not like [ __ ] it is good to be
honest you're not on the same page yeah
but maybe don't be like it wasn't the
best I've had no no no you should there
yeah you're not even close to the best
now you should be like it was pretty
good yeah that was great it was great do
the shoulders thing next time please put
less things in my butt like you know you
should communicate no no no more things
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes and then after a while no yes like
after like a couple years dude it was
actually dope man I would like I didn't
have that like
sex drive which you know I do like
having but it was nice to Tamp that down
for like five years and I could just be
around people and be like I'm fine I'm
trying to [ __ ] anything with you yeah
I'm [ __ ] myself I don't do it every
day yeah in the arm yeah yeah
it was interesting and then when I got
off of it dude that was crazy it was
like I was jerking off like I was 18
again
welcome back welcome this is a year and
a half ago and you're still going at it
yeah
uh I hate to do this but I think I gotta
go because I gotta get back and change
and then get to Vulcan okay yeah
honestly I was kind of bored anyway
wait this wasn't the best podcast you've
ever had because this was the best
podcast I've ever had three times
no Settlers of Catan if you know okay uh
yeah check check all you guys out on
Instagram